♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - Après deux ans de pandémie
sasans rassemblements,
leles inauguration officielle
d'd'écoles se multiplient ce
prprintemps au Centre de servics
scscolaires de Montréal.
(c(cris de joie, applaudissemen)
♪♪ ♪ ♪
LeLe 31 mai, c'était au tour de
seses élèves s dans Ahuntsic-
CaCartierville de célébrerer.
LeLeur école primaire Louisbourg
vivient d'être agrandie.
- Notre nouvelle école prend
vivie.
- - En plus de ce grand gymnase,
ilils profitent maintenant de
ququatorze nouvelles classes
vivitrées dans une aile flambant
neneuve et colorée. L'École
LoLouisbourg peut maintenant
acaccueillir 150 élèves de plus.
MOMOHAMED HAFAIEDH, élève 4e ane
EÉcole primaire Louisbourg
- - C'est vraiment beau.
LeLes agrandissements, pour moi,
çaça a fait... Ça a fait des
émémotions, beaucoup d'émotions.
SASAADA ABDEN-SADIGH, élève 6e
anannée École primaire Louisboug
- - On pourrait dire qu'on se
coconcentre mieux parce qu'a'av,
onon était vraiment plus s serr.
- - 25,5 millions $ ont été
coconsacrés par Québec pour cete
écécole. Un investissement parmi
bibien d'autres. Depuis dix ans,
8989 projets. Des agrandissemens
susurtout, et quelques nouvelles
coconstructions ont été lancés u
CeCentre de services scolaires e
MoMontréal. Près de la moitié st
teterminés.
ISISABELLE GÉLINAS, dg, Centre e
seservices scolaire de Montréal
- - On est très content de voir
quque ça s'installe graduellemet
papartout sur le territoire.
IlIl y a encore des enjeux, mais
papas nécessairement en teterme
d'd'espace. Sauf quelques s pets
enendroits.
- - Le secteur Griffinintown,
papar exemple, dont la populatin
a a explosé, attend toujours
sasa nouvelle école primaire.
MaMais d'autres quartiers,
cocomme Mercier, dans l'est de
lala ville, ont plus de chance.
GUGUILLAUME GEOFFROY, dir. adj.,
CeCentre de services scolaire ML
- - Ici, on est dans l'Agora,
lala pièce centrale de l'école;
lele corridor du deuxième étage.
PuPuis, on peut voir au plafond
lele puits de lumière qui permeà
lala luminosité de rentrer.
- - Grand responsable des proje.
GuGuillaume Geoffroy nous a fait
vivisiter cette nouvelle école,
rurue Hochelaga, qui accueillera
enen septembre des élèves de
mamaternelle, première et deuxie
anannée.
- - Notre intention, c'est de
réréaliser une dizaine de projes
cocomme celui-ci par année.
LaLa tendance c'est temps-ci,
c'c'est des écoles très vitrées,
trtrès lumineuses, avec des
esespaces communs.
- - Cette nouvelle annexe
pepermettra de retirer les huit
clclasses modulaires installées
dadans la cour de l'école Saint-
LoLouis de Marillac, à proximit.
SuSur la centaine de classes
plplacées dans des roulottes par
lele CSSDM en 2018 faute d'espa,
auau moins une vingtaine ne sont
plplus nécessaires. À Montréal,
lala pénurie de locaux est aussi
dedevenue moins criante en raisn
dede la COVID. Moins
d'd'immigration, exode vers
lala banlieue, le Centre de
seservice scolaire a perdu
242400 élèves en deux ans.
- - Ceci étant dit, depuis
ququelques semaines, quelques
momois, on voit que la clientèle
rerevient sur l'île.
AlAlors l'immigration a repris.
O On accueille déjà plusieurs
cecentaines d'élèves par sesema.
- - Le Centre de services scolae
MaMarguerite-Bourgeoys, qui coue
lele territoire ouest de la Vil,
fafait face aux mêmes défis.
AuAucune nouvelle école n'est
prprévue à ouvrir l'an prochain,
mamais deux projets seront
ininaugurés, dont l'agrandissemt
JuJusticier derrière moi de
l'l'école secondaire Paul
GéGérin-Lajoie, dans Outremont.
LeLes agrandissements sont une
bobonne nouvelle, mais la vétusé
dedes écoles de la ville reste
unun problème qui influencera
auaussi la rentrée. En trois an,
QuQuébec a accordé 5 572 millio$
auau Centre de serervices scolas
dede Montréal popour des
rérénovations.
- - On a une stratégie de la bae
auau SRM. Pour réussir à atteine
nonotre objectif, qui est
acactuellement de réhabiliter
l'l'ensemble des écoles à un
niniveau de vétusté en deçà de
1515  % autour de 65 %. Si
jeje prends la moyenne globale u
paparc, on a de grands besoins
dadans nos écoles.
- - À la rentrée, six écoles
seseront donc fermée
tetemporairement, le temps d'ête
rérénové. Les élèves de l'école
LaLaurier, sur le Plateau Mont-
RoRoyal, s'apprêtent à déménager
dadans Villeray pour deux ans.
C'C'est cet ancien centre de
loloisirs complètement réaménagé
ququi les accueillera. Ça
ococcasionne des stress, des
sosoucis. C'est à quatre
kikilomètres d'ici, il y a un
mémétro et des bus. Non, ce n'et
papas drôle de s'adapter.
SiSi on décide d'habiter ici,
c'c'est pour une école de
ququartier.
- - Les aléas qui impliqueront a
rerentrée, Maisonneuve dans l'E,
popourrait attendre jusqu'en
dédécembre avant de réintégrer
leleur école.
- - Envoie, ces temps-ci, qu'ily
a a une augmentation considérabe
dedes prix.
LeLe manque de main-d'oeoeuvre n
a a beaucoup de misère à
s's'approprier le matériau.
- - Quels que soit les obstacle,
chchaque projet termrminé est un
grgrand pas pour le bien-être et
lala réussite des s élèves.
EtEt aussi, pour l leur fierté.
(c(cri